- [Instructor] We're told that a group
of three friends is
practicing for the track meet.
The group is going to
run 1/2 of a mile total.
If they each run the same distance,
how far will each person run?
Which expression could
represent this situation?
So pause this video and try to
figure this out on your own.
All right, the way I think about it is
there's some distance that
they're going to try to travel.
So in this case, it's half of a mile
and they're going to divide that distance
amongst the three friends.
And so the distance that
each of them are going to run
is the total distance divided
by the number of folks that are running.
So an expression that
represents this is 1/2,
the total distance they're running,
divided by the number of people
who are going to split that
distance, divided by three.
And so that is choice C right over here.
Now it might have confused you a little
because you're not used to
dividing a smaller number,
especially a fraction, by a lager number
but that's exactly what's
going on over here.
You're taking the total distance
and it's being split
amongst three friends.
So the total distance
divided by three friends
will tell you how far
each of them has to run.
Let's do another example.
So here, we are, actually
they're telling us
that there's some problem
that can be solved
with 1/2 divided by seven.
They say which problem can we solve
with 1/2 divided by seven?
And then they give us
three different scenarios
that we could try to solve.
So pause this video and think
of which of these three scenarios
can be solved with this expression.
All right, let's go through
each of the choices.
Cara ordered seven pizzas
for her birthday party.
Her parents ate 1/2 of a
pizza before the party.
How much pizza is left for the party?
All right, so what's going on here?
She started with seven
pizzas, she starts with seven.
Her parents ate 1/2 of a pizza.
So 1/2 of a pizza is taken away.
And so that would tell
you how much is left.
So this is definitely,
this is the expression
you would solve to figure out A,
not this expression up here.
So I would rule this out.
Walt has seven hamsters.
Each hamster weighs 1/2 of a kilogram.
What is the total weight of the hamsters?
Well to figure out the total weight,
you would start with
the number of hamsters
and you would multiply that
times the weight of each hamster.
So that would be seven times 1/2,
so we could rule that one out.
So it's likely going to be C
but let's figure this, let's
make sure it makes sense.
Jenae has 1/2 kilogram of trail mix.
She splits her trail mix
evenly between seven friends.
How much trail mix will each friend get?
All right, she has a total
amount, 1/2 of a kilogram
and she's going to
divide that total amount,
she splits her trail mix
evenly between seven friends
so she's going to take this
1/2 and split it evenly
amongst seven friends to get
a certain amount per friend.
How much trail mix will each friend get?
And that's exactly what
that expression up there is
so I am liking this choice.